all right let's turn to some more
serious news RET family member and
former dancing toes Samantha Harris her
battle with breast cancer and Brooke you
made huge news with this interview
yesterday oh well she's got such a
positive outlook Robin remember that
several doctors told her she was fine
after she found a lump there was really
her self awareness or strong will that
led to that diagnosis and now Samantha's
facing the next difficult step that is a
double mastectomy
are you scared I'm frightened timing
it's a major surgery
I'm 40 years old and I'm before the
lumpectomy I had never been cut in two
before as she battles stage one cancer
Samantha told me she also worries about
the cancer recurring so she considered
two options one a lumpectomy with
radiation to a double or bilateral
mastectomy she chose the mastectomy I
need to have the best possible chances I
can possibly know that I can have and so
that to me was the thing that made me
decide welcome to the world-famous
Carlton pier in can with her filing
reports from around the world as an ET
correspondent to eight seasons on
Dancing with the Stars
audiences have seen Samantha's
professional side but as a friend I know
her personal life means even more she
and her husband Michael have two
daughters Hilary three and Jocelyn who
six are you emotional about losing part
of yourself you know what I'm more
worried about not having feeling because
you sort of lose all sensation in your
chest wall so I'm a young woman I want
to be able to feel my body I know I I
know my body really well which is what
helped me discover the lung well a it
sort of you know it's sort of sad
we're not it's okay but you know I think
just that I'd also you know having just
something that's foreign inside you yeah
I'm worried about what I'm gonna look
like not not to everyone else but to
myself naked in the mirror it's it's
scary and Samantha is doing everything
with a sense of humor my husband and I
celebrate our 10 year anniversary at the
end of May I think happy Anniversary
honey
didn't know if you signed up for those
but you're with me now and you don't and
he has been he's been great